[Music]
it's time for you to grow up and accept
responsibility what do you think of when
you think of plastic surgery are you
here to get my snatch tight fish lipped
women on the Real Housewives series may
be aging Hollywood actors have kind of
looked like burn victims Michael
Jackson's disappearing nose or Lindsay
Lohan's rubberized lips when internet
slideshows of plastic surgery fails are
only a mouse-click away it's easy to
think about facelifts icheb's and all
the rest as the province of people who
refuse to grow old the way nature
intended but that's not the only way and
it's certainly not the best way to think
about plastic surgery as the new
documentary take my nose please makes
abundantly clear there's actually one
class of celebrities that will be very
honest about cosmetic procedures they've
undergone you don't look exactly like
the Joan Rivers I used to them and that
would be comedians directed by the
nearly 90 year old journalism legend
joan crone take my nose follows two
actresses as they contemplate getting
work done along the way viewers learn
the history of modern plastic surgery
and are exposed to a powerful argument
that plastic surgery is just one more
way of improving ourselves like diet
exercise and education crowns
wide-ranging funny suspenseful and
erudite movie drives home the
libertarian point that nips and tucks
are about self actualization and self
reinvention not immature fears of
growing old or a sign of unrestrained
narcissism there's one thing joan chrome
knows it's self reinvention born in 1928
and raised in new york city crone
studied costume design at Yale's
Graduate School she skipped undergrad
before getting married to a Philadelphia
doctor she joined the city's Arts
Council in the 1960s and brought Andy
Warhol in the Velvet Underground to
perform at the ywh a and she began her
journalism career at 41 years of age
after the collapse of her marriage she
moved to New York where she became the
Wall Street Journal's first fashion
writer wrote for New York magazine and
was a regular at the New York Times
Magazine
she became editor-in-chief of the
high-end lifestyle magazine Avenue she
was in her sixties when she started
writing a beauty column for allure and
in 2000 she
a book like the count of getting her own
facelift to visit Crone in her art rich
Upper East Side apartment is to be
granted an audience with a woman who has
blazed a unique trail through the last
century of American life hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason and today we are
sitting down with Joan Crone she's the
producer and director of the fascinating
new documentary about plastic surgery
called take my nose please Joan thanks
for talking to us thank you
what do you hope to accomplish is it to
make plastic surgery either more
acceptable or to have a wider
conversation oh I didn't do this for a
cause I wanted to make a movie but I
wanted to make a movie about something I
knew about what is it about plastic
surgery that people find both compelling
and yet they resist it at the same time
it's it's a fascinating subject because
it's about science it's about psychology
it's about horror in a way because it's
the fear that a person could change them
their appearance
it's about deception and it was also
about making yourself better looking and
it it is capable of doing all that but
it's also capable of making you worse
looking why do we why do so many people
draw the line at surgery to enhance or
to make yourself feel better about
yourself so you have all kinds of
psychological reasons why people are
against plastic surgery and they attach
it to an idea that it's better to be
natural and there is no such thing as
natural if we were natural you know our
hair would be our nails would never be
cut and I here would be down to the
floor and change is very frightening to
a lot of people it's exciting and it's
also frightening and it can be dangerous
but it's not as dangerous as you think
it is introduce us to the the two main
characters that you follow as they're
thinking about having plastic surgery
and other things are going on in their
life there's Emily and Jackie who is
Emily and
why does what does she want and why does
she want Emily askin is a unknown mostly
to most audiences she's an up-and-coming
improvisational comedian I've always
said that I have some unfortunate angles
I have a Jewish nose I mean that's
probably offensive to people but I'm
Jewish so she studied at the school that
Amy Poehler started which is the Upright
Citizens Brigade which is a comedy
school I stumbled on her and when I was
looking for somebody to be a star of
this film I googled her and I found out
that she has a beauty salon in
Pittsburgh where she did at that time
and I called her up and when I told her
the name of the film take my nose please
she said oh my god I've always wanted
mine and I was done and she has she has
a bump in her nose it is sort of like
philosophical dilemma to alter your
appearance just because you can she has
a bump not a very not a very serious one
nothing that you might not even notice
it and but it bothered her and I took it
to leading a prominent doctor in New
York and Jake because I don't believe
that I should be a diagnostician
and she had a chance to talk to the
doctor and discuss her problem our
issues and then she decided that she
might want surgery the viewer doesn't
know until you've really till the end
what happens so one of the plastic
surgeons who is an expert in the film
talks about how different different
types of people are better or worse
candidates for plastic surgery and
people who have low self-esteem and are
doing it because other people are
telling them that you're not pretty
you're not good-looking you would look
better this way
they're not good candidates for plastic
surgery whereas people who are kind of
more inner directed seem to be what what
is going on there sometimes people focus
on
a small defect or what they perceive as
a defect and think if they change that
it will change their life when really
there are other things going on in their
lives and making these small changes
does not make them happier because
that's not really the problem and so he
just he describes it as body shame and
body dissatisfaction of the two
different and if you have body
dissatisfaction you know that it's not
everything and that you could live your
life and you'd be okay but if you fix it
you might be a little happier and people
who have bought a shame believe that
there's something that is there that
that makes them ashamed and they feel if
they take that away they will feel
better about themselves but often the
problem is much deeper psychologically
we're making it sound very boring movie
isn't boring the movie is exciting
because the movie is about comedians
they have families they have love they
have problems they have issues and
within a kind of a bigger story about
their lives we're talking about how
plastic surgery impacts them but
comedians have historically been the
only people who have been honest about
plastic surgery among celebrities and
celebrities practice what I call they
take the hypocritical oath they lie
about their plastic surgery and say
they've never had it and and then in
private they do have it this is the kind
of change that we're talking about
regardless of how you look people are
gonna judge you so you
as well like looking in the mirror you
have a clip an interesting clip from
Jane Fonda finally admitting that she
had had and she in a way to go back to
the discussion of natural beauty she
always said no I just worked out a lot
or I and I just ate right and all of
that kind of stuff
and she cops the other protagonists in
the movie is Jackie who is a comic
actress very well known and she talks
about in in a in her routines about how
ugly she is how a she's a dog if you
think I'm self-loathing now you're lucky
you didn't see the one-woman show I did
when I was five you want to do something
to your face Jack is the only woman I
mean I've been covering this field for
25 years she's the only woman who I've
ever heard say I'm ugly and I know it
just a very sad year woman say that and
I was drawn to Jackie because she gave
an interview in The Wall Street Journal
thing that she regrets not having a nose
job that her mother offered when she was
16 now if your mother offers you a nose
job when you're 16 you have to live with
this burden of knowing that somebody
thinks that you really need a nose job
and she's gonna give it to you and the
movie can be seen as just a funny
hysterical take on plastic surgeon
surgery and comedians because we have a
lot of comedians and a lot of jokes and
a lot of laughter but there's also a lot
of pain in our movie well and this you
know to talk about pain as well as
happiness or triumph there are two
female comedians who are kind of the
guardian angels
tody fields and Joan Rivers totie Fields
was a kind of zaftig you know Phyllis
Diller worth
worse than phyllis diller comedian who
died after a plastic surgery
complication arising from that Joan
Rivers talked to celebrated her plastic
surgery what is is that kind of the
Alpha and the Omega of what's possible
in plastic surgery you know a lot of
people believe that Joan Rivers died of
having plastic surgery and that's not
true and I liked to dispel that she was
having she had a raspy voice I think I
have a raspy voice and she was to having
a procedure to see what was the matter
with a rasathi cos in case there might
have been some polyps and that's how she
died and had nothing to do with plastic
surgery totie Fields was turned down by
many doctors because she had diabetes
and she was overweight
diabetes can be very dangerous with
surgery and she found with great efforts
she found people who would operate on
her and she developed a blood clot and
she developed phlebitis and lost the leg
so I wouldn't say she didn't die of
plastic surgery most people who have
died while they were having a plastic
surgery treatment do not die of the
plastic surgery operation and it's a
terribly sad thing she was only 48 years
old and it's a cautionary tale we I
wanted to show every side of plastic
surgery I didn't want to sugarcoat it
this is not a movie that is a for or
against plastic surgery it happens to be
about plastic surgery but it's also
about human beings you've read a book in
1998 called left wanting and fearing and
having a facelift
you've had three facelifts Botox relax
and Restylane and Juvederm what how did
how did that work and obviously you're
also you're 89 so yes that's right a
first-time filmmaker at 89 and it's not
dramatic right it is it's kind of making
incremental improvements in your
appearance right plastic surgery can be
extreme it can be subtle that's it's
it's a Couture operation usually the
goal is that you want to look just like
a slightly more rested version of
yourself did it work for you or hasn't
worked for you does it make you happier
doesn't make you back at the pictures of
myself when I look back at the pictures
of myself I just feel that I've been
able to stay in the game longer I'm
still working I've been working even
before I made this movie I was a
journalist and I doubt that I would have
been employed if I had just left my
face go older and older and older yes
obviously I dye my hair come on I would
have been again you know I could be at a
grave yeah lady - but I'm not does it
bother you at all that one of the facts
that comes out in the movie is that 90%
of plastic surgery is is done for women
or on women only 10% for men does it
bother you that you know Charlie Rose
who I'm sure has had work or is likely
to have had work or Dan Rather or older
journalists who are probably younger
than you you know but look much older
like they they don't have to have
plastic surgery is that an issue at all
or what what did you use the word have -
yeah you know prejudices I guess it's a
choice it's a choice you know when the
science is there why wouldn't we use it
I mean are you still riding a horse when
you could be driving a car you know it's
basically that's about what it's about
so what explains the gender or talked a
little bit about the gender issues
because plastic surgery is still mostly
a woman's well let's put it this way in
the beginning of time thousands of years
ago in ancient Egypt and the reason we
know about ancient Egypt is that there
was something called the Smith papyrus
and it's the oldest medical document
that we know about there were probably
earlier ones but we just haven't found
them okay this one was found in the 19th
century and in it there's a recipe for
how did make an old man into a youth
this is the first known treatment an
anti-aging treatment and who is it for
it's for men women did not get any of
the goodies in those days the men got
the goodies and I think we're returning
to that slowly and so yes I think men
are only 10% now but it is inching up
and maybe they're 12% and and they're
going to be many many more men doing
this and very soon I
we won't be here but you'll be here and
it'll be 50/50 one of the people in the
movie says that beauty though is the
currency for women and is that is that
changing as well or is it that and is it
changing in the sense that women don't
have to be as beautiful anymore or is it
that men have to up their game because
they're also competing now not just
against other men but women as well it's
very hard to be a woman and not notice
who gets to have a starring role on
every movie and it's it's very popular
for people to say we'll look at Helen
Mirren but there's only one Helen Mirren
and then you know and there are dozens
of starlets called you know Emma Stone's
and who are getting all the good roles
and you can't help but notice that the
prettier girls seem to get through the
ring in the in the merry-go-round right
well let's talk a little bit about your
career because and and in a I think was
an interview with AARP you said it's it
AARP magazine that it's good to be an
icon or you should create yourself as an
icon you're an icon of journalism you
started your 89 you started working as a
journalist when you were about 40 41
over the course of your journalism
career what are the big what are the big
lessons that you would give to today's
media because you know print is dying
print is being reborn broadcast why
would I give a message to anybody I said
a lesson not a message but what what are
what are the what are the lessons that
you've learned that you think are that
people might benefit from knowing
everything is transferable everything
that you do can be you know you have to
I I once got a free subscription to a
magazine that was put out by Harvard
about heart I think the Harvard Business
School and I and there was a very
interesting article is that if you're
working for somebody and they need
something you have to fulfill the needs
of
people you work for you're not gonna
keep your job for long so I you know
when I was at allure and I saw that the
tide was turning and that we started
being an Internet blog I started writing
immediately for that and I loved writing
for it because it's so immediate
I mean you write it today and it's up
tomorrow and if you're writing for a
magazine you're right today and it's up
two months from now and and that was
always that you know I'm sure you
understand that that there's such such a
long wait and things can happen to your
story and can get old it's like milk you
know and start turning sour right so I
loved writing for the yeah for our
internet and and I found that I did
better work on it I thought I did some
better work and that was because fewer
editors were putting a finger prints on
my work you know I don't know if I have
a lesson for other people's lives
it's just that what would I do if I do I
mean I just happen to be alive yeah I'm
not in charge of that there's a lot of
longevity and my family
what would I do if I didn't work I would
go shopping well I need money to go
shopping so I work and I can make a
little money and then I can go shopping
take my nose please is now currently
doing the festival circuit where is the
best place or how can people follow or
get information about where it might be
a PR next well we're about to we have
been besieged by what distributors
that's the people who are going to help
us get the film out there on the
airwaves or in the ether or whatever
it's called on video on demand or
Netflix or Hulu or whatever yeah I don't
even how to describe but I there are
generally two scene on a screen right
what is your next project I'm not going
to tell you okay my next
does about and something very important
in the plastic surgery cosmetic surgery
world that I know a lot about but I
don't think a lot of other people know a
lot about and I think a lot of people
will be interested in it and we're going
to do it in a very unusual way and I'm
making plans yeah well we'll leave it
there then we have been talking to Joan
prone she's the producer and director of
the fascinating documentary take my nose
please Joan thanks so much for talking
to us yes for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
thanks for watching
[Music]